I think I rushed the end of that
problem just to finish in
the 10-minute YouTube
time limit.
And I just want to make sure you
understand because I did
it all over the place.
We said, white to
brown is 2:3.
And then white is equal to
2/3 times the brown.
And we also said, well the total
number of baskets is
white plus brown.
White is 2/3 of the
number of brown.
So 2/3 brown plus 3/3 brown,
or 1 brown, that equals 5/3
brown is equal to the total.
Or we can multiply both sides of
this times 3/5 and say that
the brown is equal to
the total times 3/5.
And since we can't have a
fractional number of brown
eggs, the total has to
be divisible by 5.
And if you look at the choices,
the only number
that's not divisible by
5, is choice B, is 12.
All the other choices are
divisible by 5, so they could
have been possible choices.
Let's move on to the next.
And I will do it in green.
Seven.
If 18 root 18, 18 times the
square root of 18 is equal to
r times the square root of t,
where r and t are positive
integers-- and we also know
that r is greater than t--
which of the following can be
the value of r times t?
So this is is interesting.
r can't equal t, otherwise
they would both be 18.
But one interesting thing
that we can try doing.
Well actually I'm not going to
do it that way, because I
realize that might be a long
way of doing this problem.
Let's see, how can we think
about this problem?
Well, we know that r and t are
positive integers, so what
could r and t be?
18 root 18.
So we could factor this more.
We could say that this is
the same thing as 18
times 9 times 2.
In which case, this is
the same thing as 18.
The square root of 9 is 3
times 3 times root 2.
What's 3 times 18?
That's 54 root 2.
So this would satisfy
this format.
So we could say r is 54
and t is 2, in which
case rt would be 108.
Let's see if that's a choice.
And it's a choice, so we're
done, because that could be
the value of rt.
Maybe I just stumbled on it.
I don't know if there's
other choices.
I won't think too
hard about it.
But that's the answer.
I just simplified this a little
bit and I said 18 root
18 is the same thing
is 54 root 2.
And so r is 54, t is 2.
If you multiply them, you get
a 108 and that was choice C.
Problem number 8, which
I will do in yellow.
Problem number 8.
Fancy graph drawn there,
not a graph, a drawing.
See the triangle,
that's one side.
That's one side.
One side.
Then we have another triangle
inside this triangle.
Just a triangle.
Another triangle inside that
triangle and see what they
wrote in addition to that.
So this angle is b.
This angle is c.
This angle is a.
This angle is b.
This is b, and this is a.
And they want to know, in the
figure above what is the value
of c in terms of a and b?
If you've watched my geometry
videos, this to me is the
angle game because we're just
going to try to figure out as
many angles as we can.
And then eventually we'll
hopefully be able to figure
out what c is.
So we know this is b, this is
b, and all of these combined
form this supplementary
angle 180.
So we know that this angle
right here is 180 minus b
minus b, so it's minus 2b.
That's this angle right there
and then what's this angle
right here?
What's this angle?
Well, this angle is 180.
Well now does that help us?
Is that going to help me
with this problem?
This is 180 minus a minus c.
I don't think that helps
us necessarily.
This angle right here,
is going to be 180
minus a minus b.
I should have drawn
this bigger.
This angle right here is also--
because we have this
inner triangle right here.
That also is going to be
180 minus a minus b.
This angle here is going to be
180 minus this angle minus
this angle.
So it's 180 minus this angle,
which we figured out was 180
minus a minus b.
And we just figured out
that because that was
part of this triangle.
So it's 180 minus 180 minus a
minus b minus this angle here,
which is also 180
minus a minus b.
I mean it's really minus 2 times
180 minus a minus b.
And if you simplify that, you'll
get 180 minus-- we have
this twice.
You could just simplify this.
It's 2 times 180 plus
2a plus 2b.
I skipped a couple of steps.
Because the negative
distributes, then you have two
a's and 2 b's.
Then if we simplify this, we get
180 minus 360, so you get
2a plus 2b minus 180.
I just simplified this--
is this angle.
And then we also know that
this angle that we just
figured out plus b plus
c is equal to 180.
So let me move up here, I'm
running out of space.
So if we want to solve for c--
and I don't like this, this
purple is too dark-- we just
subtract everything from the
other side.
So c is going to be equal
to 180 minus 2a
minus 2b plus 180.
Because I'm subtracting this
from the other side or that'll
make it plus 180
minus b again.
So if we simplify this, so c is
equal to 360 minus 2a and
then minus 3b.
Let's see if that's a choice.
Choice E is 360 minus
2a minus 3b.
So I haven't made a silly
error, which I
thought I had made.
So you figure out this angle
in terms of a and b.
You figure out this angle
Then you figure out this angle
in terms of this angle and
this angle.
So you just keep using the
angles of a triangle add up to
180 property of triangles.
Go to the next page.
Oh, and now we're on the
free answer questions.
All right.
I think we have time
for this one.
9.
They say, t to the third
is equal to 351.
What is 4t to the third?
So the slow way of doing
this is to try to
figure out what t is.
The fast way is, well, 4t to the
third, if t to the third
is equal to 351, then 4t to the
third, you just multiply
both sides times 4.
And so 351 times 4,
4 times 1 is 4.
4 times 5 is 20.
3 times 4 is 12.
1404.
That's the answer.
And I have 40 seconds left, so
I'll wait for the next video.
See you soon.